hi there reject nation we're gonna talk
about the best x-men movie that has ever
existed Dark Phoenix before we go into
this I would like to say thank you once
again to all the primarily women over at
40x for hooking us up with another
screening I specifically sent them an
email saying are you guys doing a 40x
greeting for Dark Phoenix because we'd
love to go what was cool about this one
is you really get a good sense of
specifically fine tune this is because
this movie is not exactly actionpack of
the visuals throughout but they still
manage to utilize it for very specific
moments throughout the film so it was
like a rather subtle approach but it was
a good enhancing approach so thank you
guys once again onto this film where to
begin
I had heard word-of-mouth about this
before we walked into it around the time
we did the final trailer reaction it
just all started to sink in with me
you know I'm really starting to lose
actually I had all these hopes in like
the first couple trailers and even if
they're well I'm like you know what I I
just don't believe in this anymore for
some reason and I stated it all they're
walking out I made sure to keep my
expectations SuperDuper low I didn't
hate the movie I know some people hate
this film I don't particularly like it
John basic thoughts I mean yeah I'm
gonna kind of dam this with faint praise
I guess and say that you know I liked it
more than I thought I would I don't
think it's great but it's it's kind of
alright for at least the mess I was led
to believe it was going to be I thought
this is gonna be a total train wreck
from what everyone's been saying about
it it's got its moments it also has its
moments where it's not so good the first
act I didn't mind the movies very
serious it's like a super somber heavy
tone and in the first acted it really
worked
other than an occasional line that was
very cheesy
I was really invested in it I liked the
very personal dynamics focusing in on
the x-men how the movie was even shot at
times at times there were there were
framing devices
that look like out of a comic book I
wouldn't say like the film looks like a
comic but there were shots that I'm like
oh that feels kind of like I'm looking
at a panel it has a visual language that
throughout the movie I just thought was
a bit more interesting than I had
expected especially coming off of
Apocalypse and aspect this is Simon
Kinberg like first directing job isn't
so like in that sense I thought some of
the actual yeah capturing choices are
kind of neat I like the overall tone and
the mood that they were going for the
thing that hit me about halfway through
was this movie lacks a pulse it's kind
of like ex tears it's like a soap opera
at a certain point it's just like
dramatic there's a lack of intensity to
a lot of the pacing some people complain
about the pacing of this film in the
breathing room I personally wasn't as
bothered by it I got more character
stuff than I expected but then again the
handling of some characters I just
really didn't like oh you'll hit or miss
James McAvoy is such a good actor I
think he does a great job always I kind
of hated Charles and a lot of this movie
this one is less of a sidequest than
what he did in Apocalypse they make this
character choice with him that I think
is interesting but they play it in the
most blunt way possible to where you're
like I don't know if Xavier would ever
really behave this way given what I know
about him they basically try to do
something where his position in the
world has gone to his head and that's
interesting but the way they draw it he
just feels like a different care
it's like earned him being wrong you
know with Logan you have a very
unlikable technically an unlikable
version of Xavier yes ungrateful swears
belittles he killed off all the x-men
you love him in that movie I just
disguise is arrogant and annoying now a
sophie Turner was hit or miss for me and
a lot of this movie there were some
scenes where I thought she did a really
good job and then there are other
moments where I just didn't buy her eye
I noticed that a lot of people actually
you don't like this movie are still
really praising her I liked her a lot
actually I did not unless
I think she's better than she was in
Apocalypse yeah I like her and ty
Sheridan are both better than in
Apocalypse at least your viewing
experience will all depend on what
you're comparing this to yeah it's like
you get more Cyclops action than you
ever have
does it make up for the lack of Cyclops
in this franchise definitely not is
Cyclops still a shining standout
character this is I appreciate the
effort to make him more integral
especially in your revamp of this
Phoenix tail magneto feels like this
that's the conflicting parts Michael
Fassbender such a damn good actor yeah
but magneto is kind of honest and
interesting you know the world with him
and what he's been up to and there's not
really enough time to explore all that
much that's the breathing room issue I
really have with this movie is because
you have a lot of cool setting okay
we're in the 90s now fix havior and
magneto she and B should be 40 years old
I'm not gonna be the guy who harps on
the timeline continuity but I'll tell
you this by the time this movie ends I'm
like now you just totally did but you
don't know sense now really thinking
back I was like wait a minute so where
does sit with what a future past mess
some stuff up so anyway yeah you don't
really get some time to live in this
stuff like the x-men in here they're set
up as their super heroes and people like
mutants now magneto he has to some sort
of colony for like runaway mutants or
people looking for homes and you don't
get time to live in these cool new
concepts of something that's never been
explored in the x-men world it's just
kind of breezed over and rush it's so
dramatic it's so damn heavy but I don't
really care for a lot it was all just
thrown in my face and the issue that I
have with a lot of the dialogue in here
I'm really quick especially with Jessica
Chastain scared haha I hated Jessica
Chastain is one of the absolute best
actors working today
hated her character there's nothing she
could have done to save that performance
there's literally nothing she could have
done the most cliche heard these lines I
swear in other movies so many times
every single line she has the script all
around with its dialogue because the
tone is so self Syria it feels like a
first time director it feels like a
director who really wants to make a
stamp and go for the heavy every time
there's a cheesy line it stands out even
more than something like last stand or
apocalypse because of the tone of the
movie when the cheese is there you're
like man that is awful oh yeah yeah the
way that the scenes the writing of the
scenes even oscillates because some of
them do approach the level of nuance
that the movie clearly wants to get at
there are some scenes in here and then
bolstered by the performances too that
are kind of interesting and powerful but
then you'll get these other scenes that
are so under written that they are
completely silly and the arc with
Phoenix
you know what really annoyed me about
this film i watch the screen junkies
x-men crammed in video on the way over
to the street as we were in traffic for
an hour and a half so I watched it and
they reminded me at the end of the movie
that they set up Phoenix with the Jean
Grey does something and you see the
Phoenix image on leash and stuff and
it's kind of just not in this movie and
this whole explanation for Phoenix being
in here is an outside thing it's it's
not really look like this was gonna be a
movie that's dealing with a real
internal thing inside of her that she
can't control when really it's this
complete external thing that just got
into her it's just a celestial force
that then unlocks her own personal
trauma kind of it doesn't fully commit
to it there was approaches and I in
concept ideas that I liked of making it
more of an intimate shot film a smaller
x-men movie hearing that idea after
after like the craziness that was
apocalypse and world ending I actually
felt that it hampered the film by not
going bigger it could have gone more
extreme it could have gotten crazier
instead went by the time you get to the
finale which it seems like it's reported
everywhere before this movie came out
that the finales on the train oh by the
time you get there and I realized the
movie was gonna end soon
like not much has really happened in
this movie yeah kind of wanders off and
is confused and then you know bumps into
a whole lot of people with a whole lot
of plans for how to get her either under
control or out of control and then yeah
we get on a train and yeah you know we
fight the bad guy I know that
quicksilver's barely in Days of Future
past and he's barely in Apocalypse the
manda they had better justification to
keep him out of the movie then in this
movie no he falls down clause in his
contract this is like only one quick
another season of American Horror Story
there are some cheesy lines and cheesy
visual moments you gotta have at least
one moment with magneto and most of
these movies where he's like screaming
trying to control something heavy but
that you know most of these guys wonder
what Michael Fassbender was thinking at
the time when they're like swooping a
camera over him and all he has to do is
go yeah there's not a lot of action in
this movie but when there is action I'm
gonna give it credit I thought there
were some cool moments of yeah there's
no sequence in here um like that ass was
like the whole scene is great but you do
get some cool kills you do get some cool
moments with Cyclops even beast on the
street magneto they do some inventive
creative things that we haven't seen him
involved with action moments before you
even get a little bit of Xavier in the
field at times there are some action
moments in here that I personally did
enjoy I thought because Jennifer
Lawrence knew this was her final film I
felt like she showed up I think Jennifer
Lewis is an amazing actress I always
thought she's been miscast his mystique
but I thought she showed up for this
movie she seemed like she really gave a
damn you know to do a good send-off and
on that note the send-off element I hate
the ending of this movie the way that
wraps up with the characters and the
journey and yeah simultaneously I feel
like there was this unfair element that
curd was shooting this movie but I
didn't know about the Disney Foxx deal
and all the sudden Simon Kinberg put in
this position to make a culmination
movie capper so I know a lot of people
are upset about the way this movie ends
at the same time I feel kind of bad for
him because if this was just another
x-men movie we could have just forgot
about this [ __ ] it moved on right yeah
it could have been one of those x-men
movies now there's more of a weight to
it because we we essentially know this
is the final one of this franchise
specifically other than like New Moon is
best whatever we don't know it's gonna
actually come out in terms of a
culmination it's terrible but in terms
of just the ending notes like even if it
was a standalone movie I would have
behaved the ending honestly I would I
would have hated the way this movie I
feel like yeah this movie isn't a lot of
unfortunate positions and one of them is
that it hasn't fallen in a place in this
particular franchise where it's earned
the ability to be a longer more
substantial movie so there's also that
like this is a huge story it's a very
important comic book storyline it's a
very intense storyline this movie would
have needed more time to expand and be a
film for what they wanted to go for like
I didn't hate all the ending notes but
they do feel like let's just tie this
the music's good I like the music a lot
Hans Zimmer from what I've heard I
thought the score was right kept finding
myself be like I love this yeah the
music's great I think this is an alright
movie ultimately like when it a verge is
out I mean like yeah it's got a lot of
flaws but I was enjoying myself
and and kind of engrossed at least for
more of it than I thought I would I
guess nothing could ever be worse than
origins Wolverine for me oh this is
boring as [ __ ] even though there are
times where is this kind of dull it it's
not overall a boring film no there are
there shades of classic x-men movies in
yeah there are moments where they get
there and you're like I can see how this
movement you just don't need that
jessyca chest if you had cut out all the
Jessica Chastain stuff and made it
really focused on Jean Grey and what's
going on internally with her and just
the x-men it would have been a much
better movie yeah what instead of my
random squirrel like I'm lyrics this is
a totally different movie and now it's
like completely
overlapping and undercutting a lot of
dark Phoenix's undercutting so much of
it I put my expectations really low I
like it more than her since Wolverine I
think I like it more than apocalypse
weirdly I prefer watching The Last Stand
because that's at least super
entertaining and cheesy as [ __ ] to me
where this I'm like it starts off as
Mike in this different approach to kind
of a do you got a 5 maybe maybe a 3 if
I'm feeling real generous did you guys
see Dark Phoenix what's your favorite
x-men movie it's sad that we're living
in a day and age where I I don't want
things to end and then when you get to
the end I'm like alright I'm ready to
let it go I think all the actors are
pretty good in this movie yeah I
actually I really liked most of them
because everyone gets this is the x-men
drama you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell and
if you are going to watch this I would
say do it on 40x yeah it really does
after the experience because it's like a
s'more subtle approach that I thought
actually enhanced my viewing and all the
x-men it get their own effects in the
40s mix and that's pretty sweet too so